sur densification pollution conséquences
du réchauffement climatique toutes les
grandes capitales mondiales y sont
confrontés et cherchent des solutions
pour améliorer la vie de leurs habitants
la preuve avec ce documentaire réalisé
par Johan vanmerbach avec cette question
comment ces métropoles peuvent-elles
désormais faire évoluer la mobilité des
citadins afin qu'elles deviennent plus
écologiques génère moins de CO2 en
rendant ainsi ces villes plus
attractives nous allons en débattre
maintenant sur ce plateau de débat doc
avec nos invités Karima Delhi tout
d'abord bienvenue à vous et vous êtes
député européenne Europe Écologie Les
Verts et présidente de la commission du
transport et du Tourisme du Parlement
européen et puis votre dernier ouvrage
s'intitule dieselgate repenser la
mobilité sans diesel c'est un livre
coécrit avec Xavier Morel et publié chez
Actes Sud Arnaud passe à laquois est
également avec nous bienvenue vous êtes
enseignant en aménagement de qui se
passe et urbanisme à l'école d'Urbanisme
de Paris et membre du laboratoire la
burba vous avez entre autres codiriger
cet ouvrage métropole mobile défi
institutionnel et politique de la
mobilité dans les métropoles françaises
un ouvrage publié au presse
universitaire de Rennes olivier razmont
est enfin avec nous bienvenue vous êtes
journaliste indépendance spécialiste des
transports et de l'organisation de la
ville votre dernier livre s'intitule lui
les Parisiens une obsession française un
ouvrage publié rue de l'échiquier car il
m'a délit est-ce que vous êtes déjà allé
à Copenhague absolument avec Copenhague
qui se Targot aujourd'hui
d'être devenu la capitale mondiale de la
mobilité douce cette capitale danoise a
été largement mis en avant dans le film
que nous venons de voir on l'a vu c'est
quoi la recette à Copenhague est-ce que
c'est la recette à suivre pour toutes
les grandes villes européennes par
exemple
d'abord Copenhague elle est souvent
présent comme une ville très agréable à
vivre et c'est là où c'est assez nouveau
parce qu'ils ont fait des choix
politiques de faire que le vélo c'est
pas juste un mode de transport comme un
autre c'est un mode de transport qui est
privilégié lorsqu'on voit les politiques
publiques qui sont décidés
par personne pour nous ça paraît rien
par an mais dans un budget public c'est
quand même conséquent quand on regarde
les autres pays c'est un dixième de ce
qu'on met dans des politiques notamment
de transport la deuxième chose c'est que
ils ont ils ont ils sont arrivés à
montrer et c'est là qui est c'est génial
c'est de faire du vélo c'est pas
seulement sur l'empreinte carbone c'est
l'amélioration de la qualité de vie et
je crois qu'ils ont réussi ce que moi
j'ai tendance à dire de dire qu'on peut
allier l'écologie et qualité de vie et
le pari est gagnant-gagnant puisque
c'est politique du vélo aujourd'hui sont
bonnes pour la santé sont bonnes pour le
climat et un domaine dont on parle pas
assez je trouve mais ils sont beaux
aussi pour l'économie locale parce que
ça crée aussi des emplois
écologie et émote de vie et qualité de
vie pour reprendre votre expression
c'est tout l'enjeu de notre sujet
d'aujourd'hui finalement ça
oui en fait les mobilités si je prends
ma casquette d'historien elle se font
développer depuis on va dire le 19e
siècle avec une accélération de nos
mobilités par le chemin de fer la
voiture éventuellement l'avion et ça a
été de pair avec une évolution de mode
de vie une tertiarisation progressive de
nos modes de vie une augmentation des
surfaces disponibles par habitant dans
les logements etc notamment au Danemark
et donc c'est tout ça l'enjeu c'est de
tenir toujours nos modes de vie avec les
nouvelles contraintes énergétiques et
climatiques qui sont pas si nouvelles
mais enfin qu'on a aujourd'hui en face
et restons dans l'histoire parce que
lorsqu'on regarde un petit peu
l'histoire de cette ville Copenhague on
se rend compte que c'est dans
l'entre-deux-guerres qu'on a commencé
déjà à engager cette action politique
dont vous parlez ça tombe pas du ciel et
c'est très long à mettre en place en
réalité une politique de transport
durable et de mobilité durable dans les
grandes villes
oui et en fait on parle pas d'Amsterdam
ou des Pays-Bas dans le documentaire
mais on pourrait aussi avoir le même le
même discours sur la temporalité
extrêmement longue de construction d'un
d'un réseau cyclable et d'une habitude
et d'une culture Vélo dans ces pays-là
que nous n'avons pas construit encore en
France on a construit d'autres systèmes
de mobilité et par exemple vous prendre
un exemple qui serait l'habitude métro
marche à Paris qui s'est construite
aussi sur un temps très long par exemple
à Paris intra-muros
oui ça tombe pas du ciel vous l'avez dit
et c'est fondamental c'est à dire qu'en
fait ce qui se passe souvent dans toutes
les villes celles du documentaire mais
pas seulement on aurait pu prendre le
Ghana on pourrait entourer en prendre
d'autres c'est qu'à chaque fois il y a
des citadins qui se disent un moment on
voit très bien Berlin qui disent à un
moment bah tiens
on a envie d'avoir des quartiers plus
agréables on a envie de pouvoir se
déplacer autrement on a envie de pas
être stocké dans notre voiture tout le
temps et donc qui se mettent à faire des
choses on le voit très bien le mouvement
en fait assez populaire au départ dans
les villes se met en place les élus
suivent il y a effectivement ensuite des
observateurs des chercheurs qui
s'intéressent au phénomène mais ça tombe
pas du ciel et c'est ça qui est
intéressant aussi c'est que c'est pas
des transports qui sont plaqués d'en
haut qui arrivent soit des industriels
soit des politiques publiques mais qui
viennent tout simplement des gens qui se
disent bah tiens on a envie de
réorganiser d'abord nos vies et donc
évidemment aussi nos quartiers
il faut une volonté politique c'est
aussi ce qui ressort du film que nous
venons de voir on prend l'exemple de
Paris par exemple
le changement était assez radical par
rapport à ce qui ont été les politiques
antérieures cette volonté politique elle
est nécessaire vous dites oui ça vient
des citoyens sans doute il y a une
demande de vivre mais il faut aussi une
volonté politique en fait en
l'occurrence ils ont voté et il y a eu
plusieurs élections qui ont confirmé des
des majorités qui avaient tendance à
vouloir limiter la place de la voiture
il faut dire que dans une ville
extrêmement dense ou seulement 35% des
foyers possède une voiture pour Paris
intra-muros ben évidemment c'est c'est
relativement c'est plus facile à faire
que dans dans des villes où il y a quand
même 70% ou 80% des foyers qui ont une
voiture donc c'est en fait pas moi je
dirais que c'est pas si radical que ça
en fait dès qu'on mène dans les années
70 il commençait à y avoir une réflexion
sur ben en fait on va pas pouvoir mettre
des autoroutes partout on va arrêter de
on va on va il y a des places qui
étaient qui étaient des parkings et puis
au fur et à mesure elles ont été
piétonisées donc il y a comme il y a
quand même je trouve une continuité
qui s'est poursuivi et qui a été un
petit peu théâtralisée mais qui s'est
poursuivi ensuite dans les majorités
jusqu'à jusqu'à aujourd'hui et qui qui
continue tant bien que mal je dirais
alors vous avez prononcé au moins deux
fois déjà le mot voiture parce que si on
a bien suivi ce qui nous a été expliqué
dans ce documentaire
le vrai problème c'est de rendre
réversible la domination sans partage de
l'automobile dans les grandes villes
notamment depuis l'après-guerre l'idée
centrale c'est tout de même ça sortir
l'automobile pour la remplacer par
d'autres modes de transport on va y
venir mais c'est tout de même ça l'idée
majeure l'idée devrait être ça mais le
problème c'est que les villes ont été
construites autour de la voiture et ça
pour donc le pas qui nous est amené
c'est de plus en plus de se
désintoxiquer entre guillemets de cette
voiture malheureusement ça veut dire
aussi accompagner les alternatives mais
accompagner aussi les accompagner les
comportements et je pense qu'aujourd'hui
on est en train de vivre une vraie
révolution
mais malheureusement le politique a été
aussi n'a pas assez anticipé parce qu'il
y a eu énormément de crises on l'a vu à
Paris sur les trottinettes l'arrivée des
VTC
plein de choses qui fait que le
politique n'apporticipé aujourd'hui face
aux défis on dit qu'est-ce qu'il faut
faire moi je crois que la voiture
aujourd'hui va prendre totalement une
autre dimension on va penser on va
passer de la de la possession au partage
et ensuite il va falloir voir comment
cette cette voiture va être aussi ne
peut pas être la solution à l'ensemble
des crises de la mobilité comme on a
fait croire depuis des années et le
problème que nous avons aujourd'hui
chers experts et on le sait que c'est la
concurrence et la fracture territoriale
parce que les centres urbains
aujourd'hui pourront se désintoxiquer
parce qu'il y aura des alternatives mais
le périurbain et le rural qu'est-ce
qu'on leur propose
sur la voiture en fait évidemment c'est
un peu l'icône du problème mais ce n'est
que l'arbre qui cache une forêt
systémique c'est un vrai système dont on
est on est dépendant qui est derrière
cet objet et là où les politiques pour
continuer non pas pris le devant
suffisamment c'est que le système qui
nous est proposé est de changer juste le
moteur de la voiture de passer du
thermica à l'hybride d'huile électrique
et l'hydrogène peut-être mais ce n'est
pas à la hauteur de l'ampleur de des
problèmes de dépendance qui sont
financières ce problème de dépendance
moi j'ai un seul chiffre là en tête 55%
des trajets inférieurs à 7 km en France
inférieure à 7 km sont effectués
aujourd'hui en France en voiture alors
extrêmement dépendant les Français de la
voiture effectivement je vous laisse
poursuivre non donc problème social
aussi de dissociation de la société
entre celles et ceux qui peuvent
s'acheter une toiture celles et ceux qui
ne peuvent pas bien sûr le problème de
aussi de l'âge puisque en fait on n'a
pas on n'est pas égaux quand on vieillit
quand on est et puis donc il faut
réfléchir d'abord système c'est-à-dire
pourquoi je bouge prix de l'immobilier
carte scolaire marché de l'emploi et
formes
urbaine et donc où est-ce que je veux
vivre etc et donc c'est vraiment un
temps très long on a parlé de temps long
c'est un très long arrow sur la voiture
on la voit qu'il arrive si on veut
mettre en tension politique
c'est l'ensemble des sociétés qui ont
été organisées en fonction de la voiture
c'est pas seulement qui ont été adaptés
à la voiture c'est les en fait on a
surtout adapté des villages à la voiture
aujourd'hui ce qu'on est ce qu'on a fait
ce qu'on continue à faire c'est adapter
des petites villes à la voiture en
compte continuant à construire des des
zones commerciales d'activités autour
d'habitat qui font qu'il y a pas
d'autres possibilités parce
qu'évidemment les distances s'éloignent
on met pas de trottoir et donc ça
devient finalement le seul moyen le
moyen de transport le plus simple qui
est d'ailleurs on personnalise un petit
peu les choses et puisque vous habitez
là et c'est très facile de regarder
également cette documentaire avec un œil
extérieur comme comme le fait comme le
fer à nous sais pas quoi c'est de se
dire mais comment on fait en dehors des
villes nous on peut pas faire autrement
moi je prétends qu'en fait ça dépend des
situations c'est à dire que c'est pas
seulement individuel c'est pas moi
j'habite en ville donc je peux me
déplacer à vélo ou en métro et moi je
serai en dehors et donc je ne pourrai
pas c'est il faut réfléchir en terme de
trajet et je pense que la vraie question
aujourd'hui c'est de se dire pour les
trajets ou la voiture est indispensable
parce qu'il y a effectivement pas
d'autre solution parce qu'on a quelque
chose d'important à transporter parce
qu'on doit transporter quelqu'un qui est
il y a pas qui qui peut pas se déplacer
à pied etc ben oui évidemment mais ça
peut prendre un petit peu de temps ça
peut coûter un peu d'argent le
stationnement va être va coûter un peu
cher etc en revanche pour les trajets
pour lesquels on peut faire autrement si
on a 3 km à faire dans une ville moyenne
bah oui on peut les faire en bus on peut
les faire à vélo et je pense que l'enjeu
il est il dépasse les grandes villes et
je trouve pas qu'on aurait tort de
d'opposer comme ça d'un côté les grandes
villes qui seraient cette façon
privilégiée on le voit tous les gens qui
évoquent des gens qui réfléchit hein qui
parle ils ont tous réfléchi à la
mobilité et puis de l'autre ceux qui
auraient pas encore réfléchi et qui
serait contraint de de d'utiliser leur
voiture comment c'est un problème de
trajet vous venez de nous le dire on va
revoir un extrait du documentaire on
retourne la Copenhague regardez
lorsqu'on demande aux habitants de
Copenhague pourquoi il se déplace à vélo
on obtient des réponses très
intéressantes
parce que ça permet de faire des
économies non
parce que c'est bon pour la santé de
faire de l'exercice non alors pourquoi
choisir le vélo parce que c'est le moyen
le plus rapide et le plus pratique de se
déplacer
voilà la réponse de la majorité c'est le
principal argument qui incite à choisir
le vélo alors ça va peut-être pas vous
plaire ce qui vient d'être dit parce que
l'argument numéro 1 c'est pas la défense
de l'écologie
carimadéli c'est la praticité c'est la
proximité c'est le trajet
c'est vraiment on ne met pas en avant le
fait de baisser notre empreinte carbone
c'est vraiment pour moi c'est la qualité
de vie la véritable question aussi qui
revient c'est que eux ils ont une
culture Vélo nous nous n'avons pas en
France pas encore la Culture Vélo
lorsqu'on parle de vélo en France
souvent on considère que c'est faire du
sport alors que c'est un moyen de
aujourd'hui c'est un véritable moyen de
transport et je suis contente que le
Parlement européen et la Commission que
je préside l'inscrit dans les textes
désormais le vélo comme une voiture ou
comme un tramway comme un train est un
véritable moyen de transport la
véritable question c'est comment
allons-nous
un petit peu accompagner les gens de ne
pas avoir peur en France de faire du
vélo et c'est là où la question des
infrastructures sécurisée
l'accompagnement de ces vélos on les met
où à la sortie notamment des gares parce
que l'Inter modalité est importante tout
ça on a une feuille de route européenne
avec le doublement des pistes cyclables
doublement de l'accessibilité de ces
vélos etc même jusqu'à aller au niveau
du vélo demain du made in Europe donc on
a fait le travail maintenant comment des
états voire aujourd'hui
gouvernement se laisse larguer par la
puissance des villes c'est là où ça
devient intéressant c'est que les villes
vont être les véritables pour moi les
actrices de la transformation de la
mobilité parce qu'elles sont dans la
proximité et qu'elles veulent répondre
au quotidien vous l'avez dit tout à
l'heure au quotidien des gens
[Musique]
bien vu à Copenhague c'est qu'il y a
aussi une alliance le vélo là il est
emblématique dans toutes ces villes mais
il a besoin d'allier tout seul il
réussit pas donc là vous allez le
premier allié c'est le transport public
c'est en fait simplement et qu'est-ce
qui se passe dans les dans les pays où
ça fonctionne bien et ben il y a un
train toutes les demi-heures au mieux au
pire plutôt même un train toutes les 10
minutes à certains endroits on peut
mettre le vélo à la gare de manière
totalement sécurisée et on peut le
retrouver après on a parfois même de
vélo on peut louer un vélo à la gare
d'arrivée donc il y a toute une
organisation qui fait que le vélo sert
de moyens de rabattement pour des
trajets plus longs et on organise en
fait l'ensemble de la société avec un
système vélo qui n'est pas unique et
donc effectivement alternatif au système
voiture ça n'empêche pas que dans toutes
les villes on le voit peut-être pas
aussi bien que ça mais dans toutes les
villes il y a encore énormément de
voitures on a quand même on est on est
on est encore dans le dans le dans le
débat frontal dans le la moins le
moindre espace de trottoir fait encore
l'objet de grandes discussions et de
grandes des grandes batailles là nous
sommes sur les modes de transport le
vélo les vélos cargo peut-être aussi
pour les artisans pour un certain nombre
de d'entreprises la trottinette ce sont
les nouveaux moyens de mobiliser je
reprends ma casquette d'historien
auquel dans toutes les grandes villes en
fait ce qui est assez intéressant dans
le monde des mobilités c'est qu'il y a
assez peu de solutions elles existent
pour l'essentiel tout depuis un siècle
lesquels et on va juste les réinventer
dans un nouveau contexte et le vélo
c'est ça parce que la Culture Vélo elle
a existé si vous prenez les photos des
sorties des
usines des années 30 tout le monde a son
vélo années 50 tout le monde a son vélo
donc elle existait et après c'est devenu
le Tour de France etc et on a oublié que
le vélo était aussi un mode de
déplacement en ville donc en fait il y a
peu de solutions qui sont pertinentes le
métro le bus le tramway le vélo la
voiture éventuellement peut-être la
trottinette des engins un peu personnels
on voit qu'ils ont un peu du mal quand
même enfin voilà pourquoi pas mais ça
reste à mon avis assez marginal et donc
la question de l'innovation c'est
innover à partir de ces différents
systèmes là et donc le vélo ça veut dire
quel visage pour le vélo et ça va du
vélo classique comme on l'entend et en
France on a beaucoup cette image du vélo
normal classique jusqu'à des formes de
vélo donc cargo alors long tail etc
jusqu'à des vélos qui pourraient
peut-être se mixer avec de la voiture
légère donc ça ça existe pas encore
beaucoup ça s'appelle les véhicules
intermédiaires
technologique lorsqu'on parle de vélo
c'est vrai aussi pour la trottinette
c'est l'électricité
l'assistance électrique
c'est effectivement alors ça c'est vrai
que par rapport au vélo enfin 19e siècle
on a un changement et que c'est
extrêmement
favorable à ce que tout le monde puisse
faire du vélo homme femme il y a plus de
différence enfin tout ça ça tout le
monde sur un vélo cargo on peut emmener
la famille on est vraiment quelque chose
qui est intéressant il y a un peu
lithium mais par rapport au 600 kg de
batterie et de la Tesla vous avez
quelques kilos de batterie dans votre
vélo donc c'est sans comparaison alors
vélo moyenne mobilité aujourd'hui c'est
l'électricité qui prime on veut aussi
bannir c'est logique
compte tenu des critères
environnementaux qui sont les nôtres
aujourd'hui et indispensables on veut
privilégier l'électrique alors ça vous
pour les voitures et ça vaut pour les
vélos ça vaut pour tous les modes de
transport dit durable aujourd'hui est-ce
que ça c'est une bonne voie c'est une
bonne chose ce qu'on appelle aujourd'hui
quasiment le tout électrique à terme
alors l'électricité répond à un aspect
voire deux un aspect qui est la
pollution sur le moment dans la ville
effectivement c'est moins polluant même
si le frottement des roues des freins
polluent également mais enfin
globalement ça répond à ça si ça répond
effectivement à la question du CO2 mais
ça répond pas à tout le reste pourquoi
le vélo est intéressant qu'il soit
d'ailleurs assisté électriquement ou pas
c'est parce qu'il prend peu d'espace et
donc ça il y a un enjeu qui est
essentiel une fois plus dans les grandes
villes mais aussi dans les petites et
aussi dans pratiquement dans les
villages c'est que lorsqu'on a
davantage
davantage de comment dire des moyens de
transport qui sont plus gros bah ça
prend plus de place et on peut mettre
moins de gens et puis ça et puis en plus
c'est du coup on modifie complètement
l'espace public on a on a des ensembles
moins agréable donc
l'électricité effectivement répond à des
éléments mais c'est pas le seul donc oui
il y a une forme d'électrification du
parc qui est intéressante parce que ça
permet d'éviter des analysés négatives
ou des ou des conséquences assez
négatives mais c'est pas la seule
solution et je pense que Arnaud l'a dit
cette façon il commence à y avoir des
véhicules légers qui sont un petit peu
ni vélo ni voiture qui sont un peu entre
les deux qui sont en gros entre un gros
vélo et une petite voiture entre la
voiture est le vélo si on peut dire et
qui peuvent rendre des services pas
forcément en ville mais plutôt pour pour
les déplacements y compris à la campagne
y compris d'ailleurs il y a quelqu'un
qui qui défend ça très bien dans
l'Aveyron qui dit en fait pour
finalement monter de Millau en bas dans
la vallée à mon village qui est à 25
minutes je mets 35 minutes avec mon
alors elle appelle ça un vélo tôt qui
est à peu près entre le vélo la voiture
et puis je mettrai 25 minutes en voiture
donc ça change presque rien mais par
contre c'est beaucoup moins consommateur
beaucoup moins consommateur de
ressources beaucoup moins consommateurs
d'espace et beaucoup moins consommateur
évidemment d'autres problèmes vous
l'avez évoqué tout à l'heure c'est le
parking des vélos le pays numéro un en
terme de vélo en Europe c'est toujours
les Pays-Bas c'est toujours le pays qui
prédomine mais ils ont des normes
problèmes de parking aujourd'hui à
utrech à Amsterdam dans d'autres grandes
villes des Pays-Bas voilà le type de de
sujet qui vient sur la table très vite
lorsqu'on parle de nouvelles mobilité à
U très hâte ils sont en train de le ils
sont le font avec une avec des
stationnements vélo près de la gare
imaginons juste que ce soit pas des
vélos mais que ce soit des voitures ça
prendrait encore plus de place et alors
et c'est vrai qu'autre qui a une
réflexion que j'ai découverte il y a pas
très longtemps qui est de dire ok très
bien beaucoup de gens viennent à vélo à
la gare et ça ça prend beaucoup de place
c'est vrai mais il n'y a pas assez de
gens qui viennent à pied à la gare et
leur réflexion maintenant parce que
l'espace est quelque chose extrêmement
précieux donc leur réflexion commence à
dire comment ça
se porter vers le fait que les gens
pourraient quand ils sont à moins d'un
kilomètre de la gare ils venir à pied il
faut encourager et donc c'est pour ça il
faut faire des trottoirs il faut
réorganiser l'espace public ou pour
qu'on puisse également facilement venir
à pied et je pense que là on a tout
l'enjeu des des villes dès qu'on
commence à aller à regarder de manière
beaucoup plus précise ce qui se passe
dans telle ou tel quartier on s'aperçoit
que à certains endroits ben non il faut
pas plus de vélo mais moins de vélo dans
une rue piétonne mais il faut pas plus
de vélo il faut moins de vélo donc
réussir des des le reports vers des
modes de transport
durable passerait par trois conditions
l'offre des transports bien sûr on l'a
évoqué
multitude des offres de transport la
contrainte réglementaire et puis la
fiscalité alors là je m'adresse à la
responsable politique que vous êtes ça
c'est le le bon cocktail pour parvenir
justement à cette transition
je pense mais après il faut pas juste en
parler il faut le faire et c'est là où
on est très très en retard si je peux me
permettre c'est à dire que pendant la
France a toujours privilégié les
politiques automobiles et on a encouragé
on est dit aux gens acheter du diesel
acheter une voiture etc donc ça c'est la
première chose la deuxième chose
aujourd'hui on encourage à investir dans
les hybrides pour parler de voiture et
dans l'électrique financièrement oui
mais ça ne marchera pas dans la mesure
où cette voiture électrique sera
inaccessible et elle prendra regarder le
poids et la taille des véhicules
aujourd'hui qui sont souvent considérées
comme les mastodontes qui font peur dans
les villes on appelle ça sur le mot
terrible du SUV ça n'arrangera pas la
question de congestion etc même si ça va
émettre moins de pollution de l'air mais
la place du véhicule va être la même et
ça les pouvoirs publics et moi je le dis
et on est en train de pousser cette idée
de complètement de réguler aussi le
poids et la taille des véhicules ce
n'est plus possible et ensuite ce qui va
être totalement je pense nouveau c'est
il y a un concept qui est dans l'air du
temps c'est la ville du quart d'heure la
ville du quart d'heure
ça c'est quelque chose aussi de nouveau
qui apparaît même au sein de ma
commission c'est comme on va réorganiser
nos vies selon notre travail selon le
lieu où on habite et de voir que cette
ville du quart d'heure apporte
énormément davantage mais moi je pose
aussi la question des inconvénients
parce que quand je regarde Tardy Paris
sur le volet de logistique par exemple
il y a de plus en plus de camions etc
donc premier en plus les livraisons se
font d'une manière exponentielle
désormais problème deuxième problème
j'ai peur de cette ville du quart
d'heure qui soit des vitrines et qui ne
permettent pas aux classes populaires
justement d'y entrer et je crains que ça
ça renforce encore même dans l'urbain
des fractures alors que moi je me dis
que aujourd'hui une vraie ville
notamment la mobilité serait beaucoup
plus accessible durable etc d'abord
c'est une ville citoyenne et je pense
que les citoyens et olivierasement la
très bien dit tout à l'heure
c'est-à-dire les gens savent ce qu'ils
veulent au fait vous voyez il faut juste
leur donner la possibilité aussi de
pouvoir dessiner la ville de demain mais
comment les faire un petit peu rêver
quand on a quand on leur permet pas
d'avoir des alternatives c'est la raison
pour laquelle moi j'espère que le
concept de ville citoyenne où les gens
seront beaucoup plus à même de choisir
leurs alternatives pour pouvoir
découvrir à leur ville parce que souvent
il y a beaucoup de gens qui ne
connaissent pas leur ville et de deux de
montrer à quel point les mobilités c'est
pas de la mobilité qui est subie ça
c'est terminé le temps du 21e siècle
c'est de la mobilité choisie avec un
voilà toutes la solution vous l'avez
très bien dit elles existent au fait
maintenant il suffit juste de pouvoir
politique de les réguler de les
harmoniser et puis la révolution
numérique sera là également et donc il
va falloir aussi se permettre de que
tout ça rentre dans un tempo bon pour le
climat tout à l'heure on l'a dit mais
aussi bon dans le choix parce que le
numérique va aussi révolutionner nos
modes de transport on va revenir sur
cette fameuse ville du quart d'heure que
vous évoquez qui a été évoqué dans le
film c'est une idée notamment défendue
par Carlos Moreno qui est professeur
associé à l'Institut d'Administration
des Entreprises de Paris qui a beaucoup
contribué d'ailleurs à la réflexion de
l'urbanisation parisienne telle qu'elle
a été imaginée par son actuel mère
Madame Hidalgo je rappelle ce que c'est
à dire qu'on a un quart d'heure il
s'agirait depuis n'importe quel point de
la ville de se loger travailler accéder
aux soins s'approvisionner apprendre et
puis s'épanouir c'est pas nouilles
c'est-à-dire avoir des activités de de
loisirs vous êtes du même avis que Kar
sur ce fameux concept de la ville du
quart d'heure ça serait une ville rêvée
ou pas vraiment alors j'ai pas dit que
c'était une le concept je trouve est
intéressant mais il faut pas non plus
voir tout ça comme la réponse il y a
beaucoup de d'inconvénients également
oui alors je dirais qu'il y a beaucoup
d'illusions aussi c'est que on sait
aussi et que les gens ont gagné de temps
dans les transports des temps de
déplacement quoi qu'on déplace on
augmente le nombre de réseaux on n'a
jamais gagné de temps donc j'entends
d'envie du quart d'heure que je vais
tout faire en un quart d'heure mais en
fait à la fin de ma journée j'aurais
passé 80 minutes en déplacement donc ça
alors j'espère les faire plutôt à vélo
et à pied qu'en voiture ça je suis
d'accord mais dans ma vie j'aurais quand
même mes 80 minutes de déplacement
premièrement deuxièmement cette ville du
quart d'heure n'est possible qu'avec une
hyper forte densité donc elle est très
parisienne intra-muros donc 2 millions
d'habitants et peut-être un peu moins
même et les 10 millions en dehors et ben
c'est la ville de de une heure deux
heures trois heures donc fracture
sociale comme vous l'avez dit et puis
il me semble aussi que cette ville du
quart d'heure est une ville extrêmement
tertiaire par définition parce qu'on n'a
pas de place pour de l'industrie pour de
l'agriculture et donc c'est une ville
qui est très dépendante quelque part
d'un monde très tertiarisé très numérisé
et qui moi me semble pas en accord avec
le monde qui arrive qui a un monde de
l'énergie renouvelable de moindre
disponibilités énergétique et donc de
côté matériel bien plus présent dans nos
vies de gens qui vont travailler
beaucoup plus de leurs mains y compris
agricoles et donc c'est pas compatible
avec une ville du quart d'heure dans les
métropoles tels qu'elles existent
peut-être dans des beaucoup plus petites
villes à Nevers ou à Châteauroux mais
voilà donc je suis assez réticent sur le
la question du ville du quart d'heure là
on commence à aborder la ville du futur
il y a un exemple qui est intéressant
dans le film que nous venons de voir
c'est cet aéroport de checkle à Berlin
lorsque là on va partir de rien on va
tout refaire sur cette grande espace qui
était celui de cet aéroport c'est sans
doute plus facile de tout imaginer en
partant de zéro que d'avoir à
reconstruire quelque chose sur un
urbanisme existant c'est ce qu'on essaie
toujours de faire c'est toujours un rêve
d'urbanisme de recommencer à partir de
zéro égale c'est intéressant parce que
de toute façon nous ont déjà un autre
aéroport c'était un peu Love qui est
toute façon déjà un parc donc finalement
pourquoi ne effectivement ne pas ne pas
en faire une sorte de cité idéale la
question que ça pose quand même c'est
celle pas tellement la densification
parce que je la trouve en l'occurrence
plutôt bien trouvé à ta gueule il va
enfin au passage avoir une vraie
desserte en transport alors que
l'aéroport n'en avait pas tant que quand
il était un aéroport mais mais la
question c'est celle également de des
métropoles des très grandes villes
est-ce qu'elles ont vocation encore
accroître et quand on entend tout ce
discours y compris d'ailleurs sur la sur
la ville du verdeur où il faudrait
toujours aller plus vite finalement
c'est un peu ça le message est-ce que
est-ce que c'est à l'horizon est-ce que
selon l'ONU en 2050
ça n'est pas soutenable ça n'est pas
sous table en termes de de ressources en
termes de en termes d'hydrocarbures etc
et en termes de vie l'Île-de-France
aujourd'hui est une région qui c'est un
repoussoir quand on regarde les chiffres
de la démographie elle gagne des
habitants mais elles gagnent des
habitants uniquement par la natalité
quand on regarde l'évolution depuis 15
ans bien avant le covid on s'aperçoit
qu'en fait l'Ile-de-France perd des
habitants en termes d'attractivité pas
seulement Paris et également toute
l'ensemble de la région et donc pourquoi
parce que les gens peuvent plus des
transports qui sont qui sont bondés n'en
peuvent plus de se poser la question de
savoir qui vont à chaque fois qu'il faut
un trajet combien de temps je vais
mettre etc et puis les prix de
l'immobilier donc il y a un vrai une
vraie question qui est le dégonflement
des métropoles au profit des villes qui
en ont besoin de villes moyennes de
petites villes qui ont qui aimeraient
avoir davantage d'habitants et
d'activité alors puisqu'on est dans le
futur on va voir un deuxième extrait de
ce documentaire on va à Singapour cette
fois là-bas il commence déjà à imaginer
ce que pourrait être l'urbanisme du
futur
c'est ainsi que Singapour imagine
l'avenir une vie urbaine sur plusieurs
niveaux avec sous terre des voies de
circulation dédiées aux voitures et aux
trains et sur les toits des immeubles
des parcs et des pistes d'atterrissage
alors Karima délire ils vont un peu
c'est vrai que Singapour c'est loin de
chez nous et puis en même temps là-bas
on construit verticalement on essaye de
trouver d'autres solutions pour répondre
à cette surdensification dont on parlait
à l'instant de ces grandes métropoles de
ces grandes villes est-ce que c'est ça
l'avenir moi je ne crois pas et là je
suis d'accord avec ce mot illusion voilà
nous vend du rêve un petit peu je crois
pas c'est comme là dans le reportage on
parlait aussi des taxis volants on est
en train de rêver juste après moi je
crois pas en fait que ce soit ça je
crois la verticalité c'est pas une
solution qui peut être aussi envisagée
alors en fonction évidemment du du
contexte urbain dans lequel il peut
s'inscrire mais la verticalité par
exemple c'est quelque chose en arabe
beaucoup peur notamment Paris il y a eu
un énorme débat sur building ou pas
building la verticalité davantage de
verticalité par exemple c'est pas
quelque chose tu crois pas que ce soit
franchement je crois pas du tout que ce
soit la solution je crois que et ça a
été un petit peu dit mais il y a le
futur va aussi nous nous amener d'autres
solutions par exemple le covid nous a
amené une autre forme de travail
le télétravail nous a ce qui est un vrai
beau sujet sur lequel bouleversement
bouleversement mais un vrai sujet sur
les mobilités c'est-à-dire
qu'aujourd'hui on a envie aussi d'un
moment de se poser de se dire je veux un
peu moins bouger alors je dis pas que
tous les métiers peuvent le faire parce
que ça c'est aussi une espèce
d'injustice de métier mais ça amène
quand même à une réflexion de comment je
me déplace sur le type de travail donc
je crois que le futur il y a ça et
ensuite vous l'avez un peu dit mais je
crois que le vrai le 21e siècle va être
la question de l'intermodalité comment
on peint on passe d'un moyen de
transport à un autre d'une facilité
incroyable Oliviera ce monde disait tout
à l'heure le train hop je sors je prends
un vélo et
un transport en commun ça ça va être
l'enjeu parce que justement je crois que
c'est un des ex un des leviers d'action
pour réconcilier les territoires parce
que je crois que on n'a pas assez parlé
on parle pas assez des territoires ou de
réconciliation des territoires les
fractures aujourd'hui sont tellement
grandes la question des gilets jaunes
n'a été que un exemple dont on a
toujours pas il faut le dire régler la
question mais je pense que ce sont des
questions sur lequel il va falloir
encore beaucoup travailler vous avez
souvent revêtu votre habit d'historien
je vais vous demander l'espace d'une
minute de revêtir celui de de futuriste
par rapport à cet exemple de Singapour
par rapport à ces exemples de
verticalité par exemple de mobilité
aérienne aussi qui sont envisagés à
l'avenir alors quand même reprendre ma
casquette d'historien en disant que ça
fait depuis au moins un siècle on
imagine que la mobilité sera aérienne
individualisée donc ce qui a mis en
avant un prospectiviste si on peut dire
comme ça qui s'appelait Robida dans les
années 1890
vous voyez que la sortie de l'Opéra à
Paris c'est que des gens en holocoptère
pour le prendre comme ça évidemment ça
n'arrivera jamais et tous on sait dans
le monde de la mobilité qu'on a c'est un
cimetière de ce genre d'innovation
depuis au moins un siècle donc parce que
ça n'a pas de pertinence ça peut marcher
techniquement oui ça va voler avec trois
personnes mais ça n'a aucun aucune
pertinence de créneau ni même de
durabilité écologique mais de créneaux
pour être utile à quoi que ce soit
ce sera le mot de la fin oui c'est vrai
que c'est très étonnant d'imaginer qu'on
va consacrer de l'argent de l'énergie à
créer un moyen de transport qui va qui
devrait être utile à quelques personnes
d'ailleurs la personne le promoteur de
ces de ces hélicoptères le dit lui-même
d'autant plus que ces personnes en
question peuvent précisément font partie
totalement des gens qui peuvent
télétravailler donc ils ont absolument
pas besoin de se déplacer à l'heure des
bouchons ils peuvent tout à fait se
déplacer à d'autres moments donc en fait
non c'est probablement nul et non
l'avenue mais finalement quand on a
besoin de rêve un petit peu de parler
d'intéresser les gens à ce sujet un peu
arduc et la mobilité on a parfois besoin
aussi un petit peu d'imaginaire donc
pourquoi pas parlons-en et vous parlez
l'un et l'autre beaucoup et vous avez
raison parce que ça a été un
bouleversement réellement après cette
épidémie du télétravail ça ça renouvelle
la donne sur le sujet qui nous concerne
le tiers des gens qui peuvent le faire
il faut jamais oublier que le
télétravail ne suffit pas si on veut
dégonfler les villes les une grande
ville il faut pas se seulement imaginer
que ce sont les cadres parisiens qui
vont aller s'installer dans le Perche il
faut imaginer également que la région
Île-de-France dit m'a écouté de
nouvelles entreprises non ça n'est pas
nécessaire on préfère qu'elle s'installe
à Chartres ou à Dreux plutôt que plutôt
que chez nous parce que ce sera plus
vivable pour les salariés des
entreprises en question cette fois ça
sera le mot de la fin un grand merci
vraiment à tous les merci à cette
émission pour parler de mobilité durable
dans les villes de demain un vaste sujet
mais un sujet essentiel pour le
quotidien des Français tous ceux qui
nous regardent aujourd'hui vos réactions
ça sera sur hashtag des Badoc sur
Twitter à mon avis risque d'y avoir pas
mal de réactions je compte d'ailleurs
sur vous pour réagir à ce que ce qu'on
sait ces réactions si vous en êtes
d'accord merci à sel massali qui comme à
l'accoutumée m'a aidé à préparer cette
émission et puis je vous donne
rendez-vous tout simplement pour un
prochain débat doc et ça sera bien sûr
avec son documentaire et son débat à
bientôt
[Musique]